I think we all knew that Tom Cruise had
no fears but now we know he has no limit
we have new details on how mr. Cruise is
taking filmmaking to the final frontier
we're constantly pushing ourselves
saying what what can we do what's the
next day
Tom's new mission impossible
making a movie aboard the International
Space Station NASA confirmed they are
working with the 57 year old also
involved SpaceX CEO and new dad to
little ex ash Ark Angel Elon Musk we all
know Cruz loved to perform his own
stunts for decades
et seemed the dedicated daredevil do
whatever it takes to get the shot from
flying real fighter jets to hanging off
the side of an airplane as it took off
what were you thinking I was seeing
we you're thinking I don't want to fall
you know for Mission Impossible fallout
cruise also avoided certain death while
climbing into a helicopter mid-flight
what goes through your minds when you're
doing that
don't die and of course Tom scaled and
hung off of a mountain as well as the
world's tallest building oh and yeah Tom
never let a few broken bones stop I just
stuck my foot out just literally just a
split second too long and I knew
instantly I said it's broken I better
get over the wall
I mean I've broken my nose a couple of
times I've got teeth knocked out broken
fingers and my ankle and a bunch of
different things you know but it all
comes back together rather quickly
are you certifiable doing all these
stunts I can't help myself I can't hurt
anyone else have all the private now no
word yet on exactly what fun Cruise is
planning for his latest project but it
would be the first scripted film to be
shot out of this world
and listen to what tom told us in his
first et interview back in 1985 who
didn't grow up what you know young
American didn't grow up wanting to fly
an f-14 when he grew up you know be an
astronaut
[Music]